Luke not only are you doing the trip but
you're doing this behind the glass yeah all
access how hard was it to convince the coach
to let the cameras in a lot you don't ask him
let's go here we go
I'm already breathing hard boys go go go
get him we are underway in Australia work
for him work for him yeah baby wake
up let's go we gotta take that next
step we got to take it this year
yeah we're not [__] done yeah oh
[Music]
yeah you guys had three lines shut up let's go
to work fellas start the climb start the climb
speaking of Camp is always exciting
there's something new every year you know that we
went through this rebuild for a few years where
you were excited to see the young guys coming in
and you know you're watching their progress and
this year the expectation and much greater
on our team so it's a great feeling coming
into camp where you have great expectation
because usually great expectation means you've
done something right there's a tremendous
amount of pressure to win in your league
but in La you also have to win the
expectations are high in this city
which makes it fun I mean it should be it's Los
Angeles a lot of people want to copy this down
La is a very special City in a way where you
have your core fans and the people that LA Kings
fan they take a lot of Pride on knowing
the team and following and supporting us
and it makes it fun when you get on a good ride
because they bring everybody else along [Music]
the growth of the game here has been incredible
I mean obviously there was a big boom of uh Wayne
Gretzky came but since then winning two
cups is certainly uh changed everything
our goal is to win a Stanley Cup My Philosophy
is like if you try to win the cup you're gonna
have to make the playoffs so we're not trying to
make the playoffs we're trying to win the playoffs
[Music] we love the fact
that we're in that bucket now
where you're a contender you have a chance at it
it's kind of fun to coming into work this year
and having those expectations and knowing that
the pressure is on for us to try to win it all
right
as well
whatever Todd said I agree or my goodness
like their team president Luke robatai says the
Los Angeles Kings are embracing the expectations
shadowing their Seasons we're trying to win a
Stanley Cup and that's our goal we're going to
do everything possible to get to that goal we're
going to make you know life as best possible for
our players our entire organization the past
two seasons the Kings have been eliminated in
the first round of the playoffs this
on the heels of a multi-year rebuild
designed to get them back to the Pinnacle
of the sport Los Angeles has won [Applause]
LA's hockey team won two Stanley cups
in three seasons roughly a decade ago
and go back further and you'll summon memories
of the legendary Wayne Gretzky [Applause]
alongside fellow Hall of Famers Rob Blake
and robitaille himself [Applause]
I feel like I grew up in La I understand the
Kings fans I think it was Ken nearly that
said Amigos you and I look we those were
different most people we're not looking
to work in hockey we want to work with the
teams we love and for me it was the Kings
all these years later he's hoping his team
is approaching another Unforgettable season
a season that'll start in unconventional Fashion
After just a week of training camp the Kings will
head to the unlikely hockey Outpost of
Australia for a pair of exhibition games
we have an obligation to the game to our fans
and even to the players to expose them to new
and exciting things so we're excited about going
over there every part of even these earliest days
of the campaign is geared towards a single goal
winning a Stanley Cup and for the Kings to have
a good shot at one so much will revolve around
the longtime face of their franchise anje Kopitar
the five-time All-Star and soon to be the club's
all-time leader in games played recently signed
a two-year contract extension to stay in Los
Angeles with the hope of making another run at
a cup 36 year old season you produce more than
most 26 year olds in this league I mean what
has been the secret for you to kind of continue
to be that productive if you had a dad you know
just tweaking some stuff here and there I think
Jeffrey hockey player every athlete will tell you
that you know preparation for the season is big
and I've always known up I think a pretty good
job of of getting prepared and you know getting
my body to a point where I'm able to play 75 plus
games a season so that certainly helps and it
seems like it's been working so I'm not gonna
try and change a whole lot first one of the Year
fellas the commitment he makes to himself to the
coaching staff and his teammates he is as good now
as it was in the in the Stanley Cup years [Music]
pass take off you get it back and then a shot
pass one of our pillars is be a pro you know be
a pro when you show up to the rink how do you
do that watch Kobe come to the game every day
watch him show up to practice every day watch
him take his kids on the ice in the afternoon
where are we going big room yeah big
room all right let's go to the big room
I mean I think it's great obviously
first and foremost they're
enjoying it whatever they're doing and
selfishly speaking I tried to get him into golf
but hey they wanted figure skating so
we're not getting away from the hockey
rink so figure skating and obviously hockey
so eight hours at the hawkering sounds perfect
[Music]
I don't think I could escape with
those skates yaakov he's gonna be
seven in two weeks and Ninja's eight you
know the fact that you know I can bring
our kids here essentially to my office
so-called is is very special for me too
[Music]
[Applause]
Jakob starts getting during covid he thought of
him during covet because we're in a little bubble
and we were just he was the only kid on the
ice so he just started skating and then he
started loving it okay you ready do it and
Nisha started a year and a half ago hey
started skating she's like I want to do this too
because she was just sitting here and waiting for
him and now she's on the ice and she loves
it so we're just doing whatever they love
that's the one thing I don't want him to be
labeled and be compared to myself because
he's his own little person and I know he's
going to try his best so that's about it
as long as he's having fun that's how long
we're going to be doing this as soon as he
says he doesn't want to do it anymore we're
not going to push him for that [Applause]
was a Sully that I don't
have in my book [Applause]
he does like to celebrate that's for sure we
thought hockey takes a lot of time but figure
skating it's if you want to be good you have
to be on the ice a lot there you go and now why
all day
I'm here every other day yeah look
at her jump look at her jump now
they look good uh I'd probably say
they're better skaters than me so
uh you know hopefully they'll use
it awesome job thank you [Music]
[Music]
I'm proud of you you ready you want to eat
you're trying to manage time as best as you
can you know there's obviously my hockey
their activities rest for everybody is is
important so I think we're doing a pretty good
job and uh you know it's certainly a team effort
Island good job dude did you have fun yeah
yeah I know I saw you score good job huh
all right come on let's go yeah
good job boys good job Marquee
my concern about this trip is that they think
it's a Florida five-game road trip with two
days off in March everybody's tired so you're
giving them a little bit of space you're doing
the clean out skates uh that's not what we're
going for we're gonna go there and we're going
to work all right let's talk a little about our
schedule so let's see the Australia roster we
know all 28 going 28. uh everybody will get a
game Todd probably yeah that's a game we only
got a few extras back-to-back games really early
in training camp for some of our high mileage or
heavy lifters is a little bit of a concern for
me but we'll have to react to injury and bumps
and bruises but I think we also have to see those
kids play yeah so we know that Tower heading over
on Saturday lost day Sunday uh Monday we get in
early in the morning but it seems like messes to
off ice workout there's going to be a scrimmage
element because we don't have our regular black
and white type scrimmage that we have here
training camp and we're playing two games on the
weekend I think when we get home we're playing a
little bit of catch-up not only physically mental
but also establishing training camp again but
we can do it who's going to have the toughest
job probably Dubois new language new teammates
is going to be learning on the fly faster than
anybody but he sure seems like a bright guy
and fits the group well so far [Music] foreign
[Music] things that you like
in an organization in a city
in La just checked every box I mean there's just
something about it here that I fell in love with
right away Pierre Lupe DuBois was the King's
top Edition in the off season a 25 year old
Center who's relocated south from Winnipeg eager
to chase a Stanley Cup in his new surroundings
for us to have the opportunity to bring a player
the level Pierre Du Bois it's very rare it happens
we knew it would give us an opportunity to contend
with the other good teams in our league I firmly
believe and I know the organization does
you have to be real strong down the middle
we felt by adding pure Luke he just solidifies
that position for us he adds some size and a
little bit of snarl to our lineup and the skill
level that goes with the size fits us very well
you know everything at the rink was exactly what I
wanted from the organization the staff the players
and then everything else away from the arena was
something that was very interesting to me too
right now we're in Manhattan Beach it's
peaceful it's not far from the practice rink
on the way home every time I go
over the hill and I see this it's
there's a smile on my face you
know it's never get tired of it
all the guys live around here so it's fun
you know somebody told me it'll be like when
you're a kid and there'd be 10 bikes in somebody's
driveway and everybody's just hanging out together
I mean I've only been here for like six weeks
whether it's on the ice in the gym having lunch
together after or breakfast you know everybody's
talking everybody's extremely friendly and I knew
them as competitors and hockey players on the ice
but to get to know them and be around them every
day and it's been really amazing [Music] people
saying teams built to win watch your expectations
for this team I mean the goal is not trying to
win around we're trying to win a Stanley Cup
and that's what this team is built upon it's not
quite possible to quantify exactly what separates
a team that gets eliminated at the start of
the playoffs and one that's still standing
at the end but the Kings have worked to create a
roster that blends old faces and new ones and can
as the organization's Mantra puts it finish the
climb we have talked about finishing the climb
is that climb the top of the mountain we all
hope so we got to take it this year from the
downswing to the upswing now and we're trying to
finish the client to to go to the very top [Music]
sometimes you've got to attack that mountain more
than once you're going to Mount Everest if you
run out of oxygen you come back down you go back
up but what we don't want to do is go back down
to base count the building stage we're past that
now now the point of emphasis is we've got to win
now we're at the final push we're at the end of
it and yeah what are we going to do to finish
that climb any club that hopes to contend needs
to be fortified by veterans who can point the
way towards the destination though on the subject
of where they're headed in just a few days time
there's an unavoidable focus on one of the team's
youngest players 22 year old defenseman Jordan
Spence we love his game this kid's gone Against
All Odds his whole career and he's always kind
of seems to rise above everyone else and he's
done at junior level AHL he's at that stage
where the NHL games and the Reps in the NHL games
consistently will help him take another level and
I think he's looking forward to this trip just
with the history of Australia and obviously all
that the way when you were one I think you're the
first australian-born player in the NHL what does
this mean to you to go there and play does it have
any special meaning to you or no I think so I mean
I was born there so going back I think it's pretty
special I'm excited going to Australia but I
only have one goal goal is to make the Kings this
year you know I feel confident I feel ready to go
I think it's supposed to be a little chilly
it's like 68 65 I think something like that
I'll bring a couple sweaters maybe like a crew
neck sweater as well we had a meeting a couple
days ago about just how to adapt quickly
and just with the jet lag and everything
all the teammates and myself we actually bought
like sleep sunglasses you just wear this like
um during the night for a couple hours I
think it makes us like fall asleep easier
you know it's pretty exciting for me to go
to Australia just because I was born there
but the biggest thing for me is to try and
make the team this year and go from there
the 8 000 miles between Los Angeles and Melbourne
takes 16 hours to Traverse by air [Music]
and when the Kings touch down measures to
counteract the jet lag almost immediately
begin at the direction of the team's
strength and conditioning staff
yeah I mean we arrived at 6 a.m so you
know 17 hour time zone change I believe
the thing here is you don't generally travel that
much and have to start Camp right are you trying
to look over your back shoulder long exhale
going out of your nose our goals this week is
really just to make sure guys are feeling good
you know they've had a really good off season
they're in great shape and we don't want the
travel to become a major issue we want to make
sure that we've mitigated all of those sort of
things that come along with long-haul travel
and ten per movements a lot of reps here on
this one a long shot get both sides [Music]
all over the last one ready yep first day on
the ground getting the guys loose making sure
that work all the Kinks out and our job as
a strength conditioning staff Sports Science
staff is to make sure that we don't have
any silly injuries pop up and that they're
able to give everything that the coach
requires of them day one camp tomorrow
that's all we got it
huh
good job so far Fellas on getting here and getting
acclimatized good workout yesterday now we're
getting back to work though we're gonna get on
the ice begin to climb okay we're gonna start
today reestablishing our Concepts we'll start from
the red line in with entries and four check that's
what we're going to work on today okay so let's go
to some video here and talk about this Let It Go
okay now stop when we get into this situation
Kopi knows that he's the driver okay let's
move on now four check now we get up into
this area we have to give up the puck we
have to go work for it demon I always
talk to you at this point we need you
Puck placement is important anything that
dies in this area for Puck placement we're in
trouble we're wasting energy okay next great Puck
placement juice look at your stick okay we want
you to be physical we do you're really good at it
and continue on move on now we're going to talk
about the D and stop look where RV is RV started
dot Lane he's now surfing across and staying
above that allows our demon to get up and pinch
easiest pinch in the league is right here you
have to know your range when you pinch next stop
Q stick could have broke that up right go back
and watch next okay pressure and take walls away
here comes the rim as soon as that Rim is made we
recover here we don't linger so we've talked about
entries we've talked about four check we'll work
on that all day we'll have a scrimmage element
okay anything Phil nope good see you over there
coach
okay the good thing about being on this ice
is we have to [__] work on the floor check
there's too much ice to cover so if you're
in dot Lane here and they're coming out there
you're [__] sprinting it's not casual we'll
get enough rest but we're going [__] hard
good okay let's go let's pick it up right
where we left off resourceful coaches will
find Opportunities wherever they can so practice
today for Todd mcclellan's players will feature
drills that take advantage of the larger sheet
of ice good job Louie good job Louise get up
[Applause] yesterday just you know getting to
realize we're in Australia it was a little bit
surreal but uh we're here back to business I think
they've come ready to work and uh we're a team at
a stage right now where we have to be that way
this is mcclellan's Fifth Season at the Helm of
the king's bench he arrived here at the outset
of the club's rebuild and as times passed and
the teams improve expectations have undeniably
grown when we started here back in 19 2019 Rob
Blake and the rest of the staff had a plan to
retool the team if you will and that began on
day one when we arrived I spent time with Todd
in San Jose I played for him so I understood his
preparation I understood all that part okay smart
but some contacts some battles if we are able to
get the right players in the right age group and
the right ability and skill ability into what he
preaches on a daily basis we're not done if we
give up the puck get hunting I truly believe
that we would start having success I think we're
at that stage now come on Dewey come on Dewey
we have a lot of natural talents on our team
offensively and I think Todd has put in a good
defensive system to help us be good defensively
as well no one likes the d-man early in the year
man everything's going really well as good as we
can expect the player stepped in and done their
thing to this point so it's been uh been a good
thing so far we'll see where it goes from here
all done Kev good job good work
juice good job oh boy Dewey good work
it's pretty hot I know I don't know
how you're wearing that I was gonna
wear a sweater and I was like there's
no way someone's shorts and t-shirt
you know it came to the rink this morning felt
uh felt fine and uh yeah I mean it was tough
practice obviously first first practice of the
year and uh it was hard but it felt good out
there so that was good surprisingly felt better
than I thought you know after a long flight
um you know 15 hours be on the plane it's uh
it's hard to come out there and you know get
right back into swinging things but I think
everyone did you know a good job today we
had a good practice hard skates so um you know
body felt good and I'm excited to keep on going
white gray D half and half what was
the drill light it wasn't listening
I go to the back of the line
as much as this is kind of a
different training camp I think our first
three practices have been very successful
we're aware that we're in a different country
where this is not usual circumstances so I
think guys are almost stepping on
the gas pedal a little more than
we even do when we have the first three days of
Camp back home Drew Dowdy has won two Stanley Cups
and a Norris Trophy as the NHL's best defenseman
and even in the Land Down Under The rhythms of
training camp feel familiar to the 15-year veteran
I'm already breathing hard boys all right good
sign Dowdy has accomplished just about everything
he could have dreamed of in his career and the
rewards have been all the more meaningful playing
for the team he grew up rooting for one one one
I've been a Kings fan since I started watching
hockey I was a huge Wayne Gretzky fan a huge LA
Kings fan ever since I had that opportunity that's
all I want to do is be an la king oh yeah yeah
well we're gonna be here for a little
bit what he means to this franchise
as soon as he came in with when
he was 18 he made the difference
good job good job D atta boy Dewey he's been
the great Pro a great teammate the champion and
you know obviously a huge
huge part of this organization
Drew brings the energy the
excitement the life to to the group
say anything bad I'm gonna be quiet today
yeah very quiet you can barely get him to talk
did anybody score yet I'm gonna I'm gonna score
yeah yeah 220. it's a Munch 26 27 minutes a
night consistently and do it at a very high level
at his agent with his experience is very
helpful for where we're at not only for
for our everyday play but for developing young
prospects that was a sick place now 16 years
later uh it's been a dream come true playing for
the team and you know I hope I retire came too
good work fellas good job all
right that's enough for today boys
after the skate comes a perk
of the global series visit
a chance to switch fields of play and take the
tennis court with Australian Pro to Nasi kokonakis
ready to hit some balls you want me to for
real yeah I'm curious I'll do it I'll do it
I haven't played a couple years
but I probably still got it kinda
let's try it back in
I love tennis when I was 12 till I
was 26 or so I was playing tennis
like in the summer every day of the week [Music]
want to do a real serve against me and see
if I can get it yeah this will be fun [Music]
hahaha
can you get like code violations or
anything like if you yell at the rash
they'll give you a 10 minute I've had a lot
of those in my career yeah I can say that
[Music] get in I need a bulkhead yeah
PL uck cameraman I can't yeah it's wild
he like only tried like twice and I
had absolutely no chance okay [Music]
thank you so much awesome enjoyed it thank you
it's good fun um yeah so come to our game if
you can yeah I will oh I'm gonna try it's pretty
sick actually yeah it looks nuts on TV probably
a few fights yeah oh yeah are you gonna start
one if I'm there I'm not a fighter oh I want to
say one I look like one but you're going to the
football yeah yeah I don't think so no it's not
that far no it's good you'll enjoy Escape
yeah it is good it'll be a good atmosphere
tonight we're gonna go to watch AFL game
so that'll be a lot of fun none of us have
ever seen that sport we keep hearing it's
going to be really loud I think every one
of us is excited even though we have no idea
about any of the rules it's another element
of the cultural exchange aspect of the trip a
chance to experience Australian Rules Football
up close with a quick pre-game tutorial
just the start of another night of team
bonding [Music] [Applause] you know we forget that
during the season we don't get to do this we fly
to a city practice you play a game you leave and
you get a day off and you play a game you leave oh
to have this opportunity to have the team
in one city for like what is it seven days
it never happens so the guys are all excited
that they got to really bond together this week
we parked as a group that we're
getting something out of this trip
we were going to get better as a team
we're going to get closer as a team oh
[Laughter]
you know to win in any any sport it's
important to bond and have that team
chemistry and now we're building it here yeah
there we go let's get in there [Laughter]
it was a long journey to get here but the
benefits to roster chemistry already appear
to be paying off and then of course there's the
other stated purpose of the trip to use open
practices like this one to Showcase their Sport
and give these fans as many lasting memories as
they can the one thing I do think with hockey
when you go see it live you get a little more
into it you get more attached to it [Applause]
what do you want six the sake is sick [Applause]
for the guys we're trying to promote the game I
think we have we all have a responsibility to do
that we've got to promote the game and we've
got to do it worldwide you know just so you
have a favorite team from now on I guess thank
you of course it's not every day that the NHL
come to Australia it's a once in a lifetime
opportunity for these kids to come out and
have a stay with the boys thanks for having
us guys all right so everybody grab a pot
little ones that went on the ice the other day
that was really exciting for all of us to see
shave good shave good job it's a contagious sport
it only takes a few people to be playing it and
all of a sudden everybody's playing it I see
that happening here I think that'll stay yeah
it's exciting to to bring hockey here to Australia
and uh hopefully we can turn a bunch of
the Aussies into uh I like Hank's fans
from Melbourne Australia and Rob labor
Arena the NHL Global series presents
the Arizona Coyotes and the Los Angeles Kings
it's the first time in NHL history a game has
been played not only in Australia but in the
southern hemisphere we're heading into first
exhibition game so one of the things that we
have to do is get back to game management quickly
it's not summer hockey it's not flybys I can tell
you all that but taking penalties getting
your sticks on the Ice Line changes knowing
that we need five fresh guys on the eggs all those
things have to come back to us really quick okay
we've covered a lot of good stuff in three days
use it think about it a little bit talk about it
on the bench but play Hot and get back to game
management skills let's go [Applause] [Music]
capacity Crowds Are expected a lot of
excitement surrounding these games in a
sports crazed country [Applause] the crowd
okay and the boisterous crowd they've been
energized since they got into the building
having a lot of fun right now [Music] There
You Go sir thank you good luck let's go to work
fellas start the climb start the climb [Music]
kobacha and Boyd on the draw and we are
underway in Australia showed it early
shoot it early good job slinging it come
up with it now with a shot Off The Stick
of Stitcher and wide I like that you can get a
shot quick quick quick quick quick quick Spence
Kelly has a shot and a 6A Jordan Spence the first
australian-born player to play in the NHL Spence
up high a drive over the crossbar okay good
try good try keep going boys keep going Lewis
again down low he's at the goal line he centers
deflects in save Lewis the wrap around bid anyway
Louie keep buzzing baby still loose to the side of
the net boys good job good job [Applause] that I
would say here in Australia two thick blokes to
the Fenley box I got a feeling they'll go again
Forum work for him fiallo with it hands it off
gabra called back right side and a shot save is
made Dubois Rod then we get a whistle are you okay
what are you slashing for right off the [__] bat
trying to make the team somehow
you should make it in your sleep
the tension is palpable for just a preseason
game the pace is encouraging for the Kings
who continue to pressure the Coyote's
defense with each team playing a man
down six minutes left here in the opening
period [Music] turnover into no sails a shot
high and wide and Dodie and brown out of the
penalty blocks are squaring off at center ice
both guys getting a lot in they're
looking for the bombs that's good oh
oh first chance for many here in Melbourne
to see NHL hockey and sometimes you see this
that's [__] awesome that'll do it for period
one no score 15-7 the shots favoring La okay uh
good period you guys intensity game management
skills the hunt all that part was real good okay
once we got set up and we moved the pucker on
we're fine but we've got to [__] work we've
got to Sprint into [__] holes where you got to
have something above something below and the pop
or protect okay shooting ice shoot the [__]
thing good job coming out of our Zone let's go
if it feels like the Kings have momentum
leaving the dressing room the coyotes
swing it right back with two quick
goals as the second period begins
leaving La to mount a response suspense into the
slot hands it off campe with a shot and he scores
from Australia and Jordan Spence
is on the board let's go hi boys Betty
it's about time you did something
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause] 3-1 Arizona
let's get one even get one
can't clear piella scores
from the high slot might have been tipped in front
they got to get through this get up get up and now
here is Harbison you get a shot you take it more
to the net with a shot he scores
4-3 Arizona good decoy Phil and
that'll do it for a seven goal
second period Arizona up by one
okay that was a little bit of a reminder to us
that we got to be ready to answer the bell at
the beginning of the period good job working
your way back in there's not going to be a lot
of cute Nifty Place shoot the [__] thing
find it score some ugly goals okay let's go
after the Breakneck pace of the second the goals
stop coming in the third and the Kings Still Trail
by one in the game's final moments the King's net
is empty 4-3 Arizona 10. off the draw the puck
bounces for fiala but he's stripped by Schmaltz
ahead to Keller for Hayden empty net look and
as the horn ends game one here
in Melbourne 5-3 Arizona good
job you guys both teams salute the crowd
here game number two coming up tomorrow
start of a marathon but what did you like
best about the performance tonight from your
team I thought team wise we played a pretty
good game I really like the way we started
overall I think some individual mistakes
or errors um cost us at certain points in
the game but from a team perspective we
did some of the things we wanted to do
foreign good morning good night depending on what
time zone you're in game two the global series
in the land down under the Kings and the Arizona
Coyotes [Music] for the guys that didn't play last
night let's be ready to play and establish
our game and quickly it starts in the circle
Phil U and pl are taking care of that tonight
everybody else is following let's go let's go
an interesting sector of
the roster to keep an eye on
Jordan Spence does he penetrate this king's
roster out of training camp [Applause]
Homeland man the lights are down the anticipation
is up we're underway here in game two of the
global series let's go let's go there you go there
you go both teams come out energized in front of
another capacity crowd they're really aggressive
tonight hey they're coming but it's the Kings
who again dictate the pace from the outset good
poor check good read yes all the pieces King's
looking for a chance pretty good look come on
defensive last wide game two starting much like
game one here with the Kings controlling
early right now six to zip shots on goal
but while La dominates at full
strength after they take a penalty
coach McClellan doesn't like what he sees how
to get quicker are we talking and sure enough
a coyote's power play goal sends his team
to the first intermission down one nothing
there we're gonna see both of those
penalty kills between now [Music]
we're talking about the penalty kill
and you're paying [__] attention
right you know why aren't we moving it's
hockey 101. clear not nothing gray at all
are we clear real good job in the Face-Off
Circle you [__] let it you didn't lose
one not a single one PL way to follow okay good
start on the four check we [__] peppered him
drew the first penalty of the game Power Play it
doesn't matter who's on the [__] ice let's go
okay so let's take it up a notch come on [Music]
[Music] [Applause]
counter attack speed
[Applause]
good job this could be the final period
of the global series for this year
Australian born Jordan Spence quarterback in
the power play to start all right boys penny
well played Spencer's out there with it piala up
high fiala feeds it right side he scores Jordan
Spence picking up his second point game series
everyone here came to watch you and no one else
Spence contributing to the tying goal a
minute into the Third Jacob movar gives
La the lead later in the period the Kings
off the draw take over shot score [Applause]
the lead will hold up through the final horn
time Adrian tempe's empty Netter icing the
wind that will cap the king's trip through the
celebration and that will do it [Applause] [Music]
defeat Arizona 3-2 here in Australia
three stars being announced
right here first star who else
taking the ripping from his team case here on
a big smile you shook off first time [Applause]
exactly 2023 a global Series has come
to an end and it was great atmosphere
here in Melbourne Australia both teams
he'll head back to the States tomorrow
oh big dub it was a great experience but it's
still training camp we have four more games until
the opening season so once we get back I think
everyone will be dialed into training camp and
personally for me I'm going to be just focused on
Camp and just going from there and hopefully uh I
can make the team it's from a training camp
standpoint what did you get out of this trip
you know we would be probably further into Camp
as far as structure and work and everything goes
if we were at home but that's okay because
with this trip comes other benefits bonding
and all that type of stuff now when we get on
the plane tomorrow we can't have people fall
behind and now we'll work hard and getting back
and and starting training camp all over [Music]
expectations for a hockey team are weighty enough
before you factor in a trip to a land
about as far away as you can imagine
but as the king's assortment of baggage
is loaded up for the lengthy journey home
it's a sign the first step in their long climb
is complete even as they know the expectations
will still be shadowing them when they soon return
to more traditional surroundings [Music] foreign
next on behind the glass the hardest thing
will be the first three days coming back
we obviously both want to play only one of
us can play nice healthy competition that's
just good for everybody we need practice
time we're 10 days in the training camp
when we had three practices move it move
it move it for more inside access to the
king's training camp go to nhlnetwork.com or
follow hashtag behind the glass on social media